hurricane ida is on course to make
landfall on the u.s gulf coast forcing
tens of thousands of people to flee
their homes it's expected to hit near
new orleans late on sunday the category
4 storm is forecast to be the worst to
hit louisiana since 1850
the state has declared an emergency many
people are rushing to petrol stations to
fill up tanks
while others are boarding up buildings
president joe biden has issued an
emergency order for food water and other
supplies to be sent to the state
we decided to take off yeah because uh
just like with hurricane katrina
we're not trying to be here for the
disaster so
we ain't taking no chances we're leaving
yeah
well i've battened everything down
i have a camp down the bar
put everything inside of a building put
everything inside the building locked
everything down moved everything that
could blow away
filled up all the vehicles
put everything in the freezer have
everything ready to go
case way without power a few days
because it looks like it's coming right
at us
and another hurricane is heading up the
west coast of mexico civil protection
officials have been monitoring the
progress of hurricane nora as it makes
its way to baja california
let's get more from ultrasound
meteorologist jeff harrington he's
following all those developments for us
and joins us now jeff the situation
appears to be developing
quite rapidly because
ida is now a category 4 storm what what
can you tell us you know holla this is
just what we expected to happen ida
cooking up it would go into those gulf
of mexico waters which are very warm so
that's adding fuel to the fire here and
yes you're right this is now a category
four just as projected okay let's track
this one out together and see where it's
going it's gonna barrel in just
southwest of new orleans i want to go in
for a closer look right now and bring
you up to speed with i think the worst
case scenario we'll run this by the
numbers there we go just southwest of
new orleans this is now on monday seeing
devastating impacts here so again
looking to make that landfall cat 4 so
it's going to sustain its strength and
we're looking at winds anywhere from 209
kilometers per hour on the low end up to
250 so what that is also going to do is
give us storm surge that's literally the
ocean just rushing into the shore so
think four five meters anything on that
shoreline will be buried in water so
very life-threatening conditions can be
expected here with storm surge now we
also have to add in about 500
millimeters of rain on top of that a lot
of comparisons uh to ida being made to
katrina but we need to remember 16 years
ago new orleans was not prepared the
same way it is today but this is still
going to be a catastrophic storm any way
you look at it and the strongest
hurricane to hit
since 1850. so we talked about the rapid
intensification here all because of
these warm waters so think the darker
the red here the higher the temperature
and along that northern gulf we're
sitting at about 32 degrees so ida still
has to pass through there in fact we
could see it even strengthen a bit more
before that landfall i also want to
bring you up to speed as we are tracking
out
hurricane noir right now it has thrown
buckets of rain manzanillo almost 200
millimeters of rain over the past 24
hours it's about a month's worth of rain
within that short span and nora did make
landfall toward uh jalisco the state in
mexico just moving up that pacific coast
and look at this the darker the colors
indicate the heavier the rain here now
it's going to steer up the gulf of
california and we'll look to see if
there is an impact for the tourist hot
spot of cabo san lucas but this one has
been shifting just further toward the
east it was not expected to make that
landfall and then it did now bringing
devastating impacts here and the biggest
risk for mexico will be mudslides hella
okay jeff harrington there bringing us
the very latest on both those storms
jeff thank you very much indeed you're
welcome